hey guys it is very the 29th today so
you better enjoy it and check out the
rabbit themed google doodle today
because otherwise you'll have to wait
four more years anyway see if what
happening in seguin want to make their
games better and they're asking for you
to help them do that the sonic publisher
launched a survey which asks you about
console ownership at your top three
games across all platforms top genres
favorite sega games and gauges your
interest in mobile games there are also
a number of questions which asked you to
weigh in on how much you like sega how
you described the company and a number
of statements that you can agree or
disagree with which include things like
sago used to make high quality games and
the sega is innovative just last summer
Sega CEO Haruki satomi said Sega in the
90s was known for its brand but after
that we've lost trust and were left with
nothing but reputation we'd like to win
back the trust and become a brand once
again next up fallout shelter the game
you probably start playing but plenty of
people obviously didn't is getting its
biggest update ever guess what's in it
the new update features new additions
like crafting and a barber shop as well
as more dogs cats and Paris if that's
the thing you want flying and crapping
around your fallout shelter previous
fallout shelter updates included a photo
mode cloud support and pets as well as
seasonal themed updates you can check
out the full list of changes arriving in
the 1.4 update in a story on gamespot
Microsoft have dropped the tech specs
for their hololens today as well as a
bunch of new details about the augmented
reality device the hololens will compact
with a custom-built Microsoft
holographic processing unit 64 gigabytes
of flash memory 2 gigabytes of RAM
see-through holographic lenses to HD 16
by 9 light engine a holographic
resolution of 2.3 million light points a
holographic density of 2.5 k radiance
and a whole mess of senses basically the
more radiance and light points you've
got the better your Holograms the device
will have a two to three hour battery
life of active use two weeks of standby
time and it's passively
without the use of fans it will run
Windows 10 and be able to pick up
spatial sound gaze tracking gesture
input and voice support a post on the
official windows blog indicates that the
device which weighs in at five hundred
and seventy nine grams is fully
untethered and self-contained meaning
you won't need a pc or a console to use
it poly lens will also be able to access
the windows App Store and generate
multi-dimensional full-color holograms
at low latency to allow virtual objects
to be drawn in the real world the device
also has built-in cameras to let you
record video Microsoft has priced
pre-orders for the development kit at
three thousand dollars maybe don't get
too excited just yet the publisher also
revealed that a game featuring a young
version of rez conquer character will be
included with the kit and there's a
trailer for that game on site now the
game will change depending on the user's
real-world environment also teased where
a shooter called Robo raid and a crime
drama game called fragments you can
check out the full details from the
hololens reveal on gamespot let me know
down in the comments section what you
think of microsoft's hololens and be
sure to head to game SWAT where we've
got stories on PlayStation TV being
discontinued and pre-orders for HTC by
voters that is everything I have to tell
you about today but do enjoy your extra
day in the year and I will catch you
again tomorrow on regular old Muskoka